this is evan langer reading for writer
steve watts
ratchet and clank rift apart is only one
month away from release but before that
we received a lengthy final look at the
game and in this video we'll be
discussing our hands-off impressions
with brand new gameplay
if you like this video and want to see
more ratchet and clank rift-to-part
coverage
including our review then consider
subscribing to gamespot when ratchet and
clank rift apart begins
the pair are already famous celebrated
heroes confident in their abilities even
as they're cast
a bit awkwardly into the spotlight it's
a feeling that may be familiar to their
creators insomniac games
the studio has been steadily making a
reputation as a rock-solid developer
with a firm grasp on playstation
technology
but the mega success of 2018's
spider-man and its follow-up miles
morales give its profile an overdue
boost
now as a headliner studio for the new
playstation 5 the developer is
confidently displaying its tech prowess
while managing high expectations
after ratchet and clank are pulled into
a riff by returning villain dr nefarius
they find themselves in an alternate
dimension where the mastermind has been
dubbed emperor nefarious
separated from ratchet in this new realm
clank eventually meets rivet an
alternate universe version of his best
pal who sports blue fur and a cybernetic
arm
developer insomniac game said it
considered making nefarious alternate
dimension and nemesis story a dark
mirror that reflects the inverse of
everything we know
instead creative director marcus smith
said the studio settled on the alternate
dimension showing characters true selves
but altered by the circumstances of
their surroundings
so as a result rivet is naturally heroic
but a little impulsive like ratchet
whereas ratchet has celebrated his
victories and grown up a bit
rivet's impulsivity has helped keep her
alive in the oppressive totalitarian
regime
insomniac told us it wanted rivet to be
a loner but being alone has made her a
little awkward not cynical or
mean-spirited
in the small snippets we've seen so far
that comes through in the performance of
jennifer hale most known for a very
different energy in her confident
portrayal of mass effect's female
version of commander shepard
i don't know about your dimension but
out here things never go according to
plan
improvisation is a skill you learn very
fast
i also have a talent for improvisation
well i can't wait to see you in action
[Music]
the demonstration showed two versions of
the returning setting of megalopolis
from ratchet and clank going commando
initially we see it with the ticker tape
celebration of the titular heroes
swarming with crowds and particle
effects all of which serve as a tutorial
the bright and sunny setting is then
replaced by its doppelganger nevarius
city which is cast at night with
saturated neon lights and traffic
constantly buzzing around its exterior
the ratchet and clank series has handled
cities before but this time it looks
like it could be an actual thriving city
the team said it took a page from
spider-man to have cityscape content
streaming all around you at all times
for a sense of constant bustling
activity
though it isn't an open world game
structure it feels expansive
you're dwarfed by massive art deco
buildings and at the street level
constant movement and small details help
to push the idea that the same is
happening throughout the massive urban
landscape
while some worlds are their own static
environment other planets will show off
the conflict of dimensions and flux
these sync planets will let you explore
a world caught between both realms
by constantly swapping between their
varied states and a snap the bulk of a
ratcheting clank game isn't spent
gawking at the environments
but rather causing havoc inside of them
on that front rift-apart looks familiar
if gorgeous
i should have known scuttling you fools
would be too easy
[Applause]
were you saying something here i stopped
list
[Music]
the thing you'll never have to find out
ratchet and clank gameplay has already
been fine-tuned over more than a dozen
games and there's not much reason for
insomniac to reinvent the wheel
what we see instead are refinements and
new toys to tinker with blending the
studio's eye for varied platforming
challenges with its fine sense of weapon
design
that's where you get elements like the
topiary sprinkler a glove with a green
thumb
that turns your enemies into shrubs
inspired by the greenery art at
disneyland
insomniac said it wanted to introduce a
freezing mechanic without just another
freeze ray and the result is more cheeky
and comical
a ricochet gun based on pinball complete
with a round and silvery projectile
rewards pinpoint timing as you bounce it
repeatedly off the heads of unsuspecting
foes
the void repulsor combines a shield with
a shotgun like short range burst
and the negatron collider is said to
exemplify the mechanical implications of
the new dual sense controller
insomniac noted that the previous charge
mechanics needed to rely on a separate
input or releasing the trigger to fire
while the dual sense lets you charge and
then pull through the adaptive trigger's
resistance to let it rip
what's striking is how the fidelity of
the visual design helps create player
feedback for the weapons
we've heard about the enforcer in other
previews and how it makes use of the
dual sense controller by firing one
barrel with a partial squeeze
and then both if you click past the
resistance but on top of that you can
actually see this reflected on the
weapon itself
without glancing at the weapon hud two
indicator lights on the back of the gun
show when it's empty
partially full or ready for a full
two-barrel blast the over-the-top size
of the weapon makes this small touch
legible at a glance
that same level of care and attention to
detail seems to reflect in the
platforming segment
which transitions seamlessly with quick
cinematic flourishes one major action
set piece
as riven and clank escape from a
rampaging robot blends rail jumping
wall running and the new riff pulling
mechanic into an array of frenetic
action that may seem dizzying if it
weren't so imminently readable in the
heat of the action
rift-apart also adds more traversal
tools to make you more nimble like a
phantom dash that has you phase out of
reality for a short time for a side
strafe maneuver unaffected by gravity or
enemy attacks and even within that
action set piece
rift apart found time to insert little
moments of humor and heart
have any of you seen a little grey robot
anywhere green eyes
red antenna very charming all of this
happens within the snappy
moment-to-moment gameplay
rather than pausing to watch some story
happen and when cut scenes do occur
they're fun to watch and usually pan
right into a moment of gameplay
[Music]
can't anyone print instruction manuals
anymore it's the trick insomniac pulled
with the opening of 2018 spider-man
transitioning straight from a cutscene
to swinging through manhattan so
seamlessly you may not have even noticed
that cutscene was over
that filmic quality is mostly visible in
the characters themselves
if the world has gotten a significant
upgrade to take advantage of the ps5
it doesn't come at the cost of ratchet
clank or rivet in the case of the two
organic creatures
their faces are stretchy and expressive
like an animated film and their fur is
beautifully detailed
you can actually see the direction their
fur is brushed on various parts of their
faces and arms
clank is built to look like he was made
of actual metal materials with a visible
difference between shiny reflective
steel
and coarse brushed nickel his eyes look
like dappled led arrays
and being a metallic companion you could
see raytrace reflections on his face and
body
insomniac recently boasted that it will
have a ton of accessibility options as
well
though we didn't see all of them in
action we did hear about one handy tool
a global time slow that could be mapped
to a shortcut on the d-pad
letting you slow the world if you needed
to get past any dexterity challenges the
studio says it is possible to complete
all the trophies with the accessibility
options turned
on insomniac doesn't seem to be
reinventing ratchet and clank for rift
apart
the series has been so finely tuned and
refined over the years that it's clear
insomniac knows exactly what it is
the bells and whistles here seem to be
variations on its framework so it will
probably feel very mechanically familiar
when the game finally releases on june
11th
but like comfort food at a five-star
restaurant the taste is familiar and
cozy and the presentation
has never looked better
[Music]
don't listen to him if you're broken so
am i and i think we're pretty awesome
thanks for watching if you like this
video then consider clicking the like
button and let us know in the comments
what future rift apart videos you'd like
to see
for all things ratchet and clank stay
tuned to gamespot
[Music]
you